hi there steve here steve kaufman
my 90 day challenge continues i'm kind
of nearing the end um i think i started
on the 10th of september
october november
i got a month to
go um
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe
i said i would commit to spending the
time with the language i don't know what
i'm going to achieve however
in any language that i learn my ultimate
goal is fluency and while there's a lot
of back and forth about what fluency
means i think i've made it clear that in
my view it means
competent in the language competent but
not perfect and therefore for me
an intermediate goal here is to
understand these political podcasts that
i'm listening to
uh and i'm not there yet
and uh so a couple of things today talk
about what do you do when your interest
flags
so right now my interest or my my
determination is to to spend an hour or
two or more a day listening and and
using link to save words and phrases and
that kind of got to the point where i'm
a bit i was a bit tired of doing it
yesterday
but now
uh with the election in the us
the uh this kim jong-bay and his guests
they're talking about the u.s election
in korean
and the implications for korea and
things like that
and and i don't understand it well
enough when i listen to it and i went to
that
website to look for the transcripts and
i can no longer access the website
this pod pang whatever it is uh i put it
in my language resources but i can't so
i don't know whether it's just my
computer i've asked hannah who's now
back in korea if she can help me
but uh she said what is it the sector of
chison or whatever here i'm trying it
again it just doesn't bring up the page
so this is tremendously frustrating for
me but i'm trying to get at those texts
so that i can work them and understand
it but it also reminds me of another
thing and that is sometimes you just
don't feel like doing that activity
don't feel like working out you don't
feel like whatever it might be you don't
feel like uh studying korean
however if you then lay off
wait a day or two and then you get back
into it it's like getting back into a
comfortable old shirt or something it
feels good to get back in the in the
saddle so i'm actually really looking
forward to somehow being able to access
this material because i'm interested in
what the koreans are saying about the
american election
and again just to close out so i'm
hoping that i'll be able to ask those
access those if not i've got some other
uh texts in reserve that i can work on
uh and you know because leaving aside
the 90-day challenge
uh where i'm gonna you know i'm putting
in the time daily
uh but ultimately with korean i want to
become fluent in korean that is my
motivation that is is what motivates me
with any language i want to get to where
i can understand what people are saying
i can sit down and talk comfortably and
i'm a long way from that now
final little note
in order to work on my speaking ability
uh
i'm working on a project that i've had
in my mind for quite a while and that is
to write let's say like pyotr did for
polish 100 stories
where they will feature different
essential patterns in the language where
people try to express
what they want to do like to do wish to
do what if this however on the other
hand all kinds of standard concepts that
we have in different languages and have
a series of these stories
with questions and answers like pilger
did for polish and so that's something
i'm going to be working on with hannah
as well over the next little while so
working on towards fluency yet working
on different techniques that are going
to help me
get started speaking better
and
and yet
finding ways to motivate motivate myself
to stay with it so there you have it a
bit of a disjointed ramble
and now i gotta get back at my korean
bye for now